[Music]
all right i have
a video here by a
twitch streamer named m
but her gamer tag is nega oryx
and she ended up going off
on this really misogynistic sexist
question during her stream and so
she posted it on twitter she captioned
it with
99 of the time i ignored trolls and
banned them one percent of the time i do
this
so let's watch there's always some
dumbasses saying some [ __ ]
in every comment section ever yep here
we go especially gaming
especially if you're a chick too huh yup
especially chicks
here we go oh she freddy cougar
what color is your thong today respect
women
you just infant of a human
what did you expect did you expect to be
like blue
like what do you think people are gonna
do my dude how do you see this going
any other way and how i went
you can't take a joke he commented to
her you can't
joke can you imagine john mulaney
getting up on a stage
and pointing at a woman in the audience
and going what color is your thumb
and then she goes excuse me that's
[ __ ] up and he goes
you can't take a joke you haven't gotten
to the joke yet
we got to the part where you were being
a dick you haven't told the joke yet
google mike burbiglia i'm joking
he has a really great uh bit where he
talks about how jokes have been ruined
by people like yourself who say
shitty misogynistic things and then when
someone calls them out on it they say
i'm
joking because then people say oh we
just can't joke around in the workplace
anymore
no the rest of us can still joke
you can't because you were never joking
in the first place you were just being a
misogynistic
sexist piece of [ __ ] and then you don't
like hearing that
because someone's pulling a mirror up to
you and it makes you uncomfortable
because you know you
and you know the parts of you that are
good so in your heart you have to come
up with a narrative that makes you feel
better about the fact
that somebody's asking you to confront
the parts about yourself that you hate
the most how is she focusing on the game
right now yeah she's killing it she's
not very good at it
she's running into a wall she keeps
getting killed listen better
person because you're not right now and
i'm sorry if that's hard for you to hear
because you think you're the hero of
your own story you were a footnote in
everyone else's she killed her
but she still didn't say what color it
was yeah what the [ __ ] dude
yeah so after that that guy's like well
she's really good at putting her
thoughts together like on the spot
like i felt like i would have had right
now no it wasn't
so she she responded to that because
they were like oh my god how were you
able to play
and uh like say all of that so well oh
no i mean like the
the the caption and then the extra
animation
no but the words that were said yeah
yeah yeah yeah like her
her whole argument is so articulate
she's very smart
you know why because she's dealt with
that millions of times i'm sure
i was going oh sorry i was literally
going sorry so tip where
are you going is now she answered it she
said blue
you weren't listening so she said i was
hoping it was another one because she
goes through the [ __ ] so many times and
exactly what nick was saying like she's
just dealt with this
so much being in gaming for i think
about four years now
and she's just saying like i didn't even
have to put much thought into it because
this is these are already
words and thoughts and feelings and
emotions that i've had about this
situation that she just
finally was like you know what i'm just
gonna say it this time yeah we have
streamer friends
who game and all that and also like um
just in their instagram comments
the experience is so [ __ ] crazy it's
very different
it's way [ __ ] different dude i was
like damn
like the fact that you gotta even defend
the fact that you play games
that's weird because humans love games
yeah you don't have to be a guy in a
[ __ ]
in-cell like basement dweller to
like games everyone likes games somehow
horny people find everything
find every video every stream everything
horny people are there
they have to defend the fact that they
play games that's what's weird to me
like all the other [ __ ] like being
sexualized or whatever i feel like just
in general women get sexualized in every
type of thing that they're doing right
but especially like in game like esports
or whatever i was just
it always blows my mind because i'm like
yo everyone likes playing games
and it's the one thing that you don't
really need to
be a physically like better thing to be
in it right like for example like um
like like uh like in sports guys can
dominate because they're physically
you know more built a certain way and
they can you know that's why they'll
like laugh at
wnba or whatever and it could be sexist
that way right i do that
right but then in gaming though it's
because it's like anything that's a male
dominated industry it's such a any any
industry that's heavily male dominated
there's terrible misogyny in it like
this
it's innate but what blows my mind is
like in gaming it's like
it's just hands and eyes yeah you don't
got to be physically fit you don't got
to be superior in any way
as like when you see like the
engineering field mainly have guys
and then they still talk [ __ ] about
women being engineering being like oh
because your brains aren't like thinking
in this kind of logical sense that's why
you
shouldn't be hearing that still they
still think like that that blows my mind
every time i hear people say like i
thought we got over racism in the 90s
i'm like you never played
[ __ ] any internet game ever whenever
i hear people say that i'm like the
2000s
the civil rights kind of just happened
and those people are still alive and
mostly around
like they never played no grand theft
auto online listen to call of duty or
like
uh any type of game like xbox online
like
when you hear them [ __ ] play you feel
like you're in 2002 dude when i play
video games sometimes and someone's
being shitty
the thing about my username it could be
interpreted as a girl right
so i would just play it apart just to
like make them matter
and they'll be like this is why girls
shouldn't play video games
yes because little men the like the oh
so do that thing with your hand again
if you went little men that's pretty big
a little bit
that's average all right
hey that turns some guys on too be
careful so little men
they decide to instead of taking
responsibility for their own
where they lack they have to blame the
woman because they see a woman as
lesser than because the fact that
they're they're not even an alpha male
themselves they're so [ __ ] beta that
they have to feel some sort of power
over anyone else and they just pick on a
woman because they think they're weaker
yeah i think it's the same mentality as
like bullies in school too
like even if it's not between gender
lines it's like the guy will
put out put down any other guy that they
they feel like they can
so they have a leg up it's all on that
point they're at the bottom of this
stack and they're like well i can't make
fun of these guys because they'll beat
me up i'll make fun of some girls
yeah and exactly it's [ __ ] good in my
mind right because i was like
um is it the natural instinct to protect
women
and then i thought that that was a
normal like natural instinct that most
guys had
unless you're a beta as much that's what
i realized is later is like
oh [ __ ] like these little [ __ ]
[ __ ]
are the ones that unleash this [ __ ] on
girls
they're the nice guys who are like yeah
chicks never treat me right they don't
respect me it's [ __ ]
like they like all the bad guys all that
all that [ __ ] because they're little
cucks
you know yeah and they don't know how to
talk to like
women obviously because in this this
guy's mind was either
probably two things it was either he was
trying to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] and be
misogynistic or he was really trying to
be like
give me some attention yeah like oh this
would be cool i bet you like this
yeah yeah like what color is your
thought people are they don't understand
that you need rapport
too like if we were friends right and we
had that kind of joking relationship
and it was like not just platonic but
maybe we were flirty too
i could ask questions like that yes it's
different perhaps because you know
friends and they don't know how to treat
people like friends so they're just
socially stupid yeah yeah and
self-conscious
because then that's when they're in like
uh someone ended up
replying to her tweet of this video with
a urban dictionary's entry for it
schroedinger's
dick short fingers dick shore dingers uh
or
douchebag and the definition is a guy
who says offensive things and decides
whether he was joking based on the
reaction of people around him
it was just a joke well you could take a
joke i was one of those guys huh
little dick people do like come on
there's also this thing
where people are obsessed with being
seen as masculine because they feel like
they're not
seen as masculine and so they are so
obsessed with being seen as masculine
that actually
everyone looks at them and goes you're
[ __ ] weird dude yeah they're insecure
i know women that do that i never even
yeah like narcissists where they just
like oh no
like catty yeah they can't they can't be
wrong or they can't be seen as like
oh you need to take a joke like you're
being sensitive just chill a little bit
about being seen as
that masculine or whatever the [ __ ] they
would do so much better with
people and with friends and with women
and all this [ __ ] but they have no idea
i didn't even know like
what masculinity thing was until like a
couple
years ago like i didn't know guys or
people focused on it
oh really like you never noticed it when
people did it
a lot of times no cuz like i was i think
i was in a bubble
and my only mentality
of what is like the top alpha dog
was um it was more like um it was very
caveman
it was very primitive in a way where it
was like
uh this guy will murder you and he is
dangerous
and stay away that's so crazy
that's that's literally what i thought
in the pecking order was like
that structure yeah so it's it's very
prison mentality tyson is the most alpha
person in
yeah but even in that mentality it's
like oh i need to keep this masculinity
kind of thing so they can be that
top alpha dog too well i'm out this is
like
maybe 18 year old joe right or like the
most um
who's who's down to pave their own way
like even criminals or even mafia bosses
or anybody who goes against the grain
or a dictator or a leader in some sort
who doesn't who makes their own rules
and becomes a king
that in my mind was a leader or like a
like a
masculine like that is the alpha male
right
and then when i saw these like actors
and models and whatever
or like men that dress well or whatever
i didn't really see them as
men quote unquote because that wasn't
real power
so i guess i equated power and influence
with manhood yeah i did learn that a lot
of men end up
like seeing interpreting what a man is
in many different ways and it i
i think it's mainly because they end up
seeing their first example of what a man
is through their
father figures in their lives like their
actual father or uncles or grandparents
or whatever so then whatever they end up
portraying
pro-train poetry what the
um they end up just attaching that and
saying like that's the kind of man i
have to be and that's
what a man is my yeah the two
male figures in my family were um
in front of an audience every weekend so
maybe that's why
i started to talk or whatever be in
front of a camera or whatever
because my uncle's a pastor and my dad's
a singer
so both of them were in front of crowds
so maybe
i don't know yeah because when from the
ages between zero
to five yeah that's the most influence
that a human being
like everything that you go through in
that stage of time is what
forms you to be the person you're gonna
be like your interests like
what you end up admiring like what you
strive for
in your personality like that's all from
zero to five so yeah
probably seeing all that i did see
cops and gangsters like like
uh my friends parents that were gang
members
like they would punk teachers and other
parents
and then i would see police officers
punking
them or other people and so i think
maybe
that was where i probably got that
mentality
of that is what the alpha guy is like
who is the most feared who is the most
yeah in front of people or whatever so
don't ask girls what color the thongs
are
that's the lesson of the day they can't
take the joke don't be a schroedinger's
douchebag
i say that's like my my lady when we're
when she was in high school but we were
like
you know talking and stuff yeah but she
knows how to take a joke
[Music]
you